it's another blood-soaked wedding
ceremony on House of the Dragon but this
one was unlike any scene before in
Westeros here's what made it so unique
and how the show hinted at three
potential future couples episode 7 opens
with Lena's funeral she may have died a
Targaryen death in pentos when she
commanded vegar to incinerate her but on
driftmark she's receiving a proper
valarian sea burial her uncle vaman
delivers a eulogy at the end of which he
says that valarian blood must not thin
Daemon who has just lost his wife
Chuckles uncomfortably at this likely
his Outburst is at the far set has
become the question of raniera's
children's parentage do you keep trying
Selena
soon I'll let you make it what it looks
like you
moments later Corliss who's as committed
to Keeping Up Appearances as viserys
tells raniero's second born son luceris
that someday he'll inherit this Castle
little Luke is distraught by the idea
should he become Lord of driftmark it
would mean that everyone else is dead
and that precisely is the other hidden
message in Damon's inappropriate
laughter rhaenice on the other hand is a
pragmatic player in the Game of Thrones
and asks Corliss to use the occasion of
Lane is Wake to name Bayla princess of
and heir to driftmark instead of luceris
she knows the three brunette princes are
not really their kin but Bayla and Reyna
are and she wants their domain to remain
in the true family line history
blood
and remembers names
by the end of the episode as far as
everyone is aware the valarian family
tree will have been pruned even thinner
lanor seems to have lost a duel with his
lover Carl and has been disposed of in
the fireplace but that's all just a ruse
more on that later Fela and Reina remain
but as girls they don't carry the
valarian last name jacaris luceris and
baby Joffrey have the name but not the
blood and corliss's Legacy is in
jeopardy episode 5 marked the first
appearance of Allison's green dress
which serves as a call to Arms rhaenyra
even calls Allison to enter supporters
the greens for the first time this week
as she discusses the precariousness of
her current position with Damon that's
combined with the fact that we finally
see the princess of Dragonstone in Black
means this familial Civil War the greens
versus the blacks has truly reached the
point of no return prior to episode 7
rhaenyra was usually costumed in some
combination of creamy white gold and red
these colors are meant to symbolize if
not quite her innocence than at least
her youth or perhaps her optimism the
Targaryen colors are red and black but
black is more prominent the fact that
she's attending Lena's funeral gives her
a reason to change into a darker color
scheme but this is also the installment
in which rhaenyra and Allison themselves
come to blows it's also notable who else
is wearing black the King Damon Corliss
Raines Lenor useris and luceris Allison
and her three children are still cloaked
in a darker shade of Hightower green
even at these somber proceedings episode
7 begins with Lena's funeral and ends
with rhaenyra and Damon's wedding but
three more potential future Patrol dolls
are either referenced or subtly teased
throughout the episode aegon scoffs at
having to marry his idiot sister Elena
who's muttering to herself about black
and green spools and Dragons of Flesh
weaving dragons of thread if it wasn't
clear last week it is this week Elena is
a dreamer who appears to be able to
foretell the future though we're not
sure if she's aware of her own power yet
in the previous episode she said Eamon
would have to close an eye to get a
dragon which comes to pass
you will have a dragon one day
he'll have to close an eye that aegon
and Elena are to Wed means Allison's got
her way and refused rhaenyra's proposed
match with jaserys which had police the
king viewers can probably guess based on
Prince aegon's attitude toward his
sister alone that theirs won't be a
happy marriage this also means joserus
is free to marry someone else his mother
tells him to comfort his cousins Bela
and Reina he's mourning the loss of his
own father Harwin strong so the best he
can do is stand next to them Bala grabs
his hand in solidarity later when aemon
steals vegar it's luceris who first
defends Reina whose egg is yet to hatch
and who wanted to claim pagar against
his half-brother weddings in the Game of
Thrones Universe are conducted in
accordance with a variety of religious
and cultural Traditions one element of
many ceremonies is The Binding of hands
we see a septon wrapped Joffrey and
marjorie's hands in strips of white
fabric as they recite the customary vows
of the faith of the seven through Bran
Stark we witness rhaegar Targaryen and
lyanna Stark do the same before they're
much happier though equally short-lived
marriage for their own wedding Damon and
rhaenyra have decided to blend the rites
of old valyria with the customs of
modern day Westeros most targaryens
aren't particularly religious at least
not when it comes to the new Gods George
R.R Martin doesn't go into much detail
about Targaryen weddings except that
they are wed by Blood and fire while
earlier in episode 7 blood trickled from
Rainier's curled hand after Allison
slashed her with the catspaw dagger and
her wedding to her uncle she willingly
slices open her Palm Damon does the same
and the brand new husband and wife find
their hands impress their cut lips
together in what appears to be a
Valyrian blood ritual we don't know what
words Damon and Lena exchanged but
rhaenyra and lenor's quick wedding after
Joffrey's murder was done in accordance
with the papers 7. in contrast Damon and
rhaenyra's ceremony is conducted in
Valyrian this creates yet another source
of tension between the blacks and the
greens who were practicing devotees of
the faith of the seven episode seven
ends with a shocking Cliffhanger that's
also a departure from The Source
material a clean shaven lanor jumps into
a boat with his lover and would be
assassin Carl minutes earlier in
Showtime Damon and rhaenyra were openly
discussing the need to kill off Leonor
so they could finally be together which
would both satisfy their long simmering
desires and strengthen their bloodline
and are claim to the throne during this
conversation rhaenyra says that fire is
a prison and that the sea is an escape
and that she loves lanor Damon replies
and Grant him this kindness
setting free we see Damon approach Carl
with an offer of gold and a better life
across the narrow sea and payment for a
quick death then we see Damon break the
neck of an unknown man in a stairwell
just before Carl publicly accost Lane
are in his father's Hall when Raines and
Corliss find a charred body in the heart
they assume it's their son and last
living child and they grieve accordingly
but this body almost certainly belongs
to the man Damon silenced on the stairs
rhaenyra and Damon's carefully chosen
turns of phrase strongly suggest that
they aided Leonor and Carl's Escape by
the sea but for their scheme to work
Corliss and renice will have to believe
the horrific ruse
[Music]